Oh Rock house alright what do you know
cuz you're quarantined I'm going through
my phone and I posted this lunch in the
old school if you go to finally kid
YouTube the briefs who had people forget
we were the first ones to do this
everybody in there [ __ ] lesbian aunt
are doing it animation there we hide
polytune I don't know six years ago yeah
and we did the bust one do you remember
this story how go if you go to go to
play oh yeah that was good Regulus look
a Porsche yeah yeah and then go to
hungry hippo yes once I bought the bus
Hungry Hippos can have a movie based off
a board game what are you picking well
Hungry Hungry Hippos butts a [ __ ]
fantastic all genre choice dance
Oh stupid it's a [ __ ] there's have to
be her terrifying hippo cannibals I have
to begin to make based off a true story
and a board game
it's Hungry Hungry Hippos starring Bryan
Callen yeah I want to be a hungry hippo
no you're the badass you're the Chris
Pratt character yes like lost worlds
perhaps a little better-looking and
taller than I am
you're the kid that is young cast you
yeah okay got the gig [ __ ] eyes Amita
I'm gonna be the voice of the bird that
cleans their mouth yes it was great who
is that clean is that the boy so you're
the booze that you're the star and I'm
finally in the water where I get a
chomping guys grab my voices I'm a hero
so I gotta yeah yeah I'm the brains of
the operation HIPPA Lulu hippos stupid
I'm Kai kind of organized I'm like it's
not very good a voice is I don't do
impressions
can I be an aging super Y offensive
really no no sir we're not we're you
can't I'm an agent Roger Oh typical
offensive Asian impression that that was
around in the 60s to be clear it doesn't
mean that Asian crocodiles speak Chinese
speaks English he says a little Chinese
playing so could you Veronica Ria's
that's how I say make a widow just white
kill other guys before I send the hippos
on we are all to go with the same
licorice don't say make a wish answered
by the clans everywhere brought to you
by white supremacy watch another one go
to the gota
with us together all right we should do
these again huh should be a higher poly
again it's a great you ride because I
mean Rogen were posting the ones from
the [ __ ] uh about to bust they take a
while though well I never thought I
would see the day it's for you big brown
got well almost got in a fight so we
were piled in my Porsche at the time
which I have having that red Porsche so
I get off on the exit I mean I'm sitting
there joke and whenever to bullshitting
and I see this guy just yelling like
furious I'm like look at that guy be
with you yelling at and then Brian is uh
I think he's talking to you
so roll down the window like what's up
man anything you cut me off you son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you Baba Mike what the hell
so I'm like whatever I wrote the window
homeboy gets out of the car yeah first
he slaps the piss out of my car laughs
snitch slaps his car [ __ ] slap [ __ ]
slaps his red Porsche hard on oh hell no
and then as he makes it his way over to
my car door he kicks the car and then I
get out of the car calm calm calm cuz
you don't to escalate the situation so
he's yelling at me and he's getting
closer he's getting louder no what are
you gonna do then we get old nose to
nose and I think that he kind of went
this guy's big but he's got to be a
[ __ ]
gets in your face not knows knows to do
shorter but thick so he was more nose to
chin on you but you know like you sucked
on his nose
you could have sucked his nose you
remember what you said the facing of the
world you said sir you're pushing up
against my bubble oh good
and I'm about to bust bride's in the car
this whole time not doing he rolls down
the window sticks his head out and goes
you turn around he got in his car and I
read like three workers I'd smear his
kids and they were older like 18 20 at
least I just point out the three kids
went and stay at school and I got back
in the car we took off we just took off
yeah I'm embarrassed shout out to that
guy so much fun dude
goddamn I use one fortune we can play
these cuz we own them yeah hell yeah
give us like Ultimate Fighter yeah with
you guys for doing that didn't even show
this on the air so she this guy I'm not
gonna mention his name on the show he
lost and you drink all that alcohol you
want in the house and there's only at
the time there's only four of us less
tell stories actually sickness Jones six
you're a tree own myself that's the for
fighting right so are you guys one of
the other guys is hammered hammered
wasted all of a sudden this guy gets
super racist in the house and there's a
bunch of black guys in the house starts
throwing up racial slurs and throwing up
these you know the hit hate Hitler stuff
I'll Hitler's write his name on this
piece of paper for me all right
what do you do with the paper biggest
fight of my life the next day and I
thought it was a dream Kimbo Slice and
Marcus Jones and this and this D'Amico
and the stucco Rogers comes in my room
they go yo shop get up dog get up man
I'm like oh three large black guys
around my bed
Kim goes yo man this dude's down there
talking about our people we're about to
Jack him up
I look at thousand Jimmy oh excuse me
it's talking about our people dawg
let's go F this dude up and like listen
you guys realize I said I'm down with
the race thing but you realize I'm not
black right kudos you ain't black
nobody goes dan that's crazy
turn around leaving out here that's what
lights job you can't tell what the hell
is night I go hey Kimbo that's racist
I'll use why go
just cuz I'm athletic can fire y'all be
black yours you could be a great story
wow that's interesting man yeah why did
they [ __ ] those guys up the fight and
sewer no no no they took care of them
yeah I just staff had to get them out of
there you know
yeah that's kind you know well it's cool
story that's like hey dude what are you
in the seventies sixties yeah I don't
hear just hammered and you know I don't
know you know its prey dealing with some
other [ __ ] cartoons of so old-school
their old skills forever ago huh I know
I'm tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]